avec cette signature joe biden réactive
un dispositif historique pour faciliter
l'envoi d' aide militaire à l'ukraine
je signe un projet de loi qui fournit un
autre outil important dans nos efforts
pour soutenir les ukrainiens dans leur
lutte pour défendre leur pays et leur
démocratie contre la guerre brutale de
poutine qui coule cette loi dite de prêt
bail permet à washington de réduire les
obstacles bureaucratiques pour prêter ou
louer du matériel militaire à l'ukraine
mais aussi à d'autres pays d'europe de
l'est touchés par la guerre une aide qui
ne dépendra pas de la capacité de
paiement de kiev
le texte est basé sur un programme de
prêt bail datant de la seconde guerre
mondiale le président roosevelt qui
avait déclenché en 1941 pour envoyer des
armes à ses alliés européens combattants
l'allemagne nazie y compris à l'union
soviétique
les états unis avaient ainsi transférés
à l'urss 7000 chars plus de 50000 jeep
376 1000 camions 132000 mitrailleuses
ainsi que de l'aide alimentaire
plus de huit décennies plus tard joe
biden veut donner à cette loi une portée
symbolique il l'a signé le jour même où
la russie célébrer l'anniversaire de la
victoire sur l'allemagne nazie le
programme qui a autrefois aider le
kremlin à vaincre le fascisme sera cette
fois utilisé par kiev pour aider à
stopper l'agression russe